Crisis is over and you didn't die.
Sorry kid but this has to happen, you
play this speedster game long enough,
you learn some neat tricks
that's nice. it really does. a secret
organization has been operating in
Central City these people they live in
the darkness any absence of light they
will not be brought out of the shadows
easily now that the multiverse is gone
physics has changed entirely earth was
rebuilt. I have to do everything I can to
protect them. Earth has more threats and we
don't know where they're coming from
something's off, you've been acting kind
of different. I need to start planning for
a life without you, we don't live in
crisis mode anymore. I have to expose
this organization. Get outta there! I can't be
your damsel-in-distress anymore. Our timeline
has been re-written. With all these changes to our reality,
maybe figure out who you want to be in this
post-crisis world the anti-life equation...
the sorry, What?!
it's a techno-organic poison it's
targeted and transmitted through the big
brain it's really scary man I've never
heard of such a thing
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new flash season 6 episode 10 trailer
the crisis on Infinite Earths epilogue
this is also happening after the events
of the arrow series finale so we'll
explain what's going on with that
because there is a little bit of
crossover that's continuing in the back
half of the season it wholly anti-life
equation it looks like Darkseid is on
the horizon for the DC TV universe if
you're introducing the anti-life
equation like they name-drop during that
clip then it makes sense that you would
build up to something like the New Gods
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos we're doing a new
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from crisis on the
video so we'll just break all this down
top 10 style starting with number 10 the
title of this episode is going to be
marathon but it won't air till the
beginning of February so like I said
it's airing after the arrow serious
finale they have a big funeral for
Oliver I'll talk about that in a second
the title of the episode is marathon the
official synopsis just reads after the
citizen Irish newspaper prints an
explosive story about black hole irises
life is threatened refusing to hide from
those that are attacking her iris sets
out to expose a dangerous organization
obviously talking about black hole from
the comics
meanwhile Barry must face the
consequences of crisis and fulfill
Oliver Queen's wish for him so number
nine that's where you see Barry visiting
Diggle at Argus sitting inside some
weird prison cell here I don't know why
they're sitting inside a prison cell
talking about Oliver some of the you
might remember this Easter Egg for the
mask the Diggle is handing back to Barry
so Barry's holding Oliver's Green Arrow
mask but the reason why Diggle would be
giving that to him is because Barry way
back when they started crossing over is
the person who gave Oliver that mask so
it's sort of like Diggle is giving him
back the mask that he gave to Oliver
just like this heirloom between the two
of them that has a lot of meaning number
eight Barry's hand starts giving off
all kinds of weird Speed Force energy
that's probably the consequences that
they refer to so they changed the
timeline meaning that they changed a
bunch of stuff that we just haven't
learned about yet we'll find out in
future episodes something that might
just mess a little bit with Barry's
connection to the Speed Force he's
getting more powerful but he doesn't
totally understand everything that
happened after crisis like they changed
a few things and they learned about that
like they're all in the same earth now
but there's also a lot of other things
that got changed that he just hasn't
figured out yet the energy he gives off
also looks a little bit like earth 90
Barry Allen when he was stealing Barry's
speed look he said you've been a
speedster as long as I have you learned
a couple new tricks there was also a bit
of a teaser for future abilities that
they'll unlock on the flash there's a
lot of comic book abilities that the
flash has that they haven't done on a TV
show yet the number seven iris
narrates how crisis on Infinite Earths
is over and Barry didn't die like the
Future newspaper said because earth 90
Barry Allen took his place after
stealing his speed and just to be clear
that's just John Wesley ships earth 90
Barry Allen flash that died not Jay
Garrick so John Wesley Shipp still plays
the character who's alive on the show on
earth three and who recently started
getting busy with a version of Tina
McGee that looks just like Barry's
mother so there is a happy ending for
John Wesley Shipp the actor in all this
I'm also hoping that he cameos during
the flash movie - but I don't know who
he would play during the movie I don't
know if they're going to let him play a
character as big as Jay Garrick in the
DC movies but they just remains to be
seen it's going to be a couple years before
we see the flash movie I talked a little
bit about that in my last crisis on
Infinite Earths video when they did the
Ezra Miller scene crossing over with the
Grant Gustin flash so I'll post a link
to that at the end of this
but number six now the crisis is over
Barry and iris think that all the super
hardcore problems are taken care of and
making Netflix and chill for the rest of
the season like oh there might be some
villains that pop up but for the most
part the crisis is gone we don't have to
worry about this dark future but then
they officially introduced the black
hole storyline from the flash rebirth
comics you also notice this Easter Egg
here to the news broadcaster isn't
broadcasting from channel 52 it's
Channel 8 that's also another Easter Egg
for some of the changes they made
combining all of the earths
into earth Prime the 52 Easter Egg from
way back because they've been doing that
since arrow season 1 was a reference to
the new 52 universe of the DC Universe
in the second big crisis event called
Infinite Crisis not the same thing as
crisis on Infinite Earths number 5
during Infinite Crisis during the early
2000s alexander luthor created a new
cosmic tower using the anti-monitor
power to try and bring back his earth
that he lost the version of the
multiverse that they brought back during
that event only had 52 different earths
then they had the flash flashpoint
storyline they made a couple more
changes to their timeline and that's
then what's referred to as the new 52
era of DC Comics so any time you're
watching old episodes of arrow or the
flash and you see channel 52 on the news
broadcast that's what that's referencing
the last big DC comic book event to
change the multiverse was DC Reaper they
also dropped an Easter Egg for that when
Oliver rebooted the universe he said we
have to rebirth the universe so number 4
you have the events of the arrow season
8 finale the series finale very last
episode that's happening next week
there's a bunch of teasers and preview
pictures that they drop for that you see
them bringing back dead people most
notably Oliver's mother that's one of
the many changes that they probably made
to the timeline when they brought the
universes back there's probably a whole
bunch of other cameos for that episode
but there's an important reason why the
flash episode isn't premiering till
after the arrow series finale just
because a lot of what you see happening
during this next episode of the flash
addresses all the stuff from the arrow
finale number three it seems like
somebody has the bright idea to turn the
particle accelerator on again for the
billionth time and you see the black
hole assassin chick chasing down patch
face here who just seems like a common
thug and they introduced this big
cover-up storyline
irises news team starts to investigate
black hole who according to the trailer
has been operating out of Central City
in secret this whole time since before
the beginning of flash season one that
means that the reverse-flash probably
knew about them and didn't say anything
just because they weren't a threat to
his plans and it would only complicate
things to let them know about it before
he was ready to make his move
it seems like the black hole assassin
then starts going after team flash to
silence all of them she goes after Jo
she comes after iris Cisco says the
earth has more threats that they don't
know about don't know where they're
coming from they bring back Katee
Sackhoff Amunet black character the
chicks fighting each other in black
leather just seemed like more black hole
agents going at it then this woman here
looking at her reflection in the shard
of the mirror might be their new version
of mirror master I don't know which
episode she's supposed to debut in
number two Wally West is coming back
in the back half of the season for a big
reverse flash episode I think it's going to
be season 6 episode 14 so it's not going to
be this next episode they'll probably
use that episode to address what
happened with reverse flash during
crisis now I explained in real life the
reason why they didn't include him but
the character himself will explain where
he's been and why he wasn't around
probably hiding out inside the negative
Speed Force because that protects him
from the timeline changes it would have
also protected him from the antimatter
wave they also kind of implied that
Wally might wind up fridging reverse
flash during his episode they say
permanently defeat so that could mean a
lot of different things but obviously
number one big is the name drop of
the anti-life equation all the new gods
all the darkside implications they name
dropped it on Supergirl during the
episode that happens right after a
crisis on Infinite Earths this past week
so I'm assuming that they're just
building towards eventual new gods story
and they'll play handle that in a future
crossover we're not in the Smallville
era anymore they kind of did a version
of Darkseid on the Smallville TV show if
you're going to do character is big as
Darkseid because of the anti-life
equation you would do that for a huge
huge crossover story so everyone post
your theories in the comments below if
they're using anti-life equation this
early in the story when do you think
they'll actually pay that off with some
new gods story there's been a bunch of
big Marvel x-men news recently so I'll
try to do a video for that as soon as
possible but leave all your requests in
the
comments below everyone click here for
that scene of the Ezra Miller flash in
crisis on Infinite Earths crossing over
with a Grant Gustin flash favorite
moment hands down and click here for all
my other crisis on Infinite Earths
episode videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!